monsieur le garde des sceaux aujourd'hui
pour ce débat sur un projet de loi qui
porte un beau nom la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire
vous faites également un nom à la
chancellerie en un an vous avez connu
trois mois après votre arrivée un
premier décret demandant que vous ne
connaissez pas des actes relevant des
attributions du garde relatif à la mise
en cause du comportement d'un magistrat
a raison d'affaires impliquant des
partis dont vous auriez été l'avocat un
deuxième décret le 17 décembre qui
élargissait à l'entrée du dc
international et à l'exécution des
peines
six mois plus tard après votre arrivée
le 8 janvier le procureur général près
la cour de cassation annoncé une
ouverture d'information judiciaire à
votre encontre et celle ci était ouverte
effectivement le 13 janvier nous avions
vous nous vous avions dit saunier à ce
moment là et je vous avais dit très
précisément à quel stade de la procédure
pensez vous que cela pourrait devenir
pour l'accomplissement de vos sont de
vos fonctions vous m'aviez répondu je
résume que vous étiez ce que vous dites
toujours serein que ne vous n'avez rien
à craindre et donc finalement qu'il n'y
avait pas de problème
les choses se sont poursuivies puisque
vous avez fait l'objet d'une mise en
examen le 16 juillet je rappelle qu'une
mise en examen ça veut dire constaté
l'existence d'un style d'indicés graves
et concordants et que ceux qui vous ont
mis en examen ne sont pas d'affreux
gauchistes irresponsable tout juste
sorti de l'école mais madame drake
précisé la commission d'instruction est
à la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation a été longtemps présidente de
cour d'assises ainsi que c'est collègues
vous êtes dans une situation inédite qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui par rapport à ce
texte confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire on pourrait dire que vous
êtes donc en train de réaliser une forme
de performances artistiques vous savez
quand l'auteur lui-même est en train de
se mettre aux objets de sa propre
performance car vous êtes ministre vous
êtes en exercice il s'agit de faits qui
auraient été commis pendant vos
fonctions vous êtes ministre de la
justice vous exercer une autorité
hiérarchique sur les membres du parquet
et pourtant vous considérez qu'il n'y
aurait pas de difficulté c'est ce que
vous évoquez vous dites d'ailleurs
avec deux termes qui sont réitérées
depuis votre mise en examen je suis
serein je tiens ma légitimité du
président et du premier ministre
ma question c'est et vous monsieur le
ministre à quel stade je réitère ma
question de la procédure pensez vous que
cela pourrait devenir problématique pour
l'accomplissement de vos fonctions est
ce à dire que vous considérez que ce ne
sera jamais le cas
y compris si ultérieurement vous deviez
être condamné